Hạng không Việt Nam vẫn chuyện chính phẩy sấu xíu lời khách của bế,
tăng không về hai phần chạm sól đúng ki.
Chỉnh và Ní sấu phẩy sấu phần chăm tầm lượng khách hả của bế.
Lời vời thì chừng người liệu ở thì xanh lượng vẫn chuyện đặt người tán phẩy
bệnh triệu lời khách và tăng không về bà phần chăm sól đúng ki.
Ở lý vực một vận thải hàng hóa,
xanh lượng hàng hóa của bế đã mấy trong linh sấu nghiên bệ trăm tấn
tăng hàng một phẩy bà phần chăm sól đúng ki.
Các hả hả hảng công Việt Nam vẫn chuyện một trong mình chính nghiên bệnh tấn
tăng tăng về sấu phần chăm.
Chỉnh mười sấu phy tán phần chăm tầm sản lượng hàng hóa của tế.
Chắc vì đó thì sản lượng vẫn chuyện hàng hóa lượng liệu ở đặt
hai chăm mười sấu phẩy bộn nghiên bệnh tấn giản mệnh tấn trong xóa của tình kì.
Này thì các hả hảng công Việt Nam đang khai thác một trong lệ chính đường
bài của tế lối với 2,5 cụng giá của nhiều hủng bệnh thuộc.
Ông thời gian khách hảng công nước ngoài của bộn viên nước và bộn nghệ thuộc
hảnh hàng không đa lối mặt với nhiều rất thức nhiều áp giá tăng sản lượng
hảy thác trong các dài bộn cầu điểm.
Dễn diễn thịt tế cực ra, quý cơ mất hàng toàn tự kết địa bài công
người lái, chiếm và đất bộn phóng giá tại khu vực cả hàng không.
Cụng nhiều yêu cầu ngày càng cao về rất lượng mùen rất lực,
cụng nhiều năng lực của nhi hàng toàn.
Sau đó thì theo cuộc hàng không bị tâm các cơ quan,
được vi càng tiếp tục thực kia nghiêm các quy định của pháp luật về hàng toàn hàng không.
Tôn thủ có tiêu trận và quyến cá của tổ chức hàng không dành dụ cuộc tế A C A yếu.
Nông thời tăng cơ nhận dịt, vui cơ, lánh giả và kẹp sốt dù cho
đêm cá hợp quả hệ thống khoảng li ăn toàn SMS và xây dựng văn hoạ ăn toàn ở tất cả các độ.
Bình đau có đần đi và chiếu trách nhiệm chực tiếp về công tác bảo nhà ăn toàn tại đời đi mình.